congresswoman Lauren bobert from
Colorado and if you want to see when I
talk about Republicans are getting balls
they are starting to fight back they are
not taking prisoners and again we'll
have to see what they actually do about
it not just talk but watch this this is
just great so this is Lauren bobert
talking to Joel Roth who is the head of
trust and safety at Twitter regarding
her own personal personal and also
public government Twitter account Mr
Roth while at Twitter how many meetings
did you have with the FBI
I couldn't say for sure but more than
10. that's the reason
I couldn't say for sure more than 50.
that seems a bit High
many meetings with the FBI well we know
uh how many FBI agents worked at Twitter
while you were there I don't believe any
active FBI former FBI agents how many
worked there while you were there
I'm aware of perhaps two well we know of
at least nine because they started the
bu group chat bu for Bureau for Baker
said that there was no collusion with
the federal government and Twitter but
Mr Baker that's you you are the
collusion between the federal government
and the FBI and now with it this is such
a problem because
we're seeing censorship all over Mr Roth
Miss Gaddy did either of you approve the
shadow Banning of my account at Lauren
bobert
yes or no no I did not
to the best of my recollection well let
me refresh your memory because on March
12 2021 and Mr Roth I know you looked at
it because fascia's Twitter 1.0 had a
public interest exceptions policy which
means for members of Congress to be
Shadow banned it had to go before you Mr
Roth so I'll ask again did you Shadow
ban my account yes or no
again not to the best of my recollection
so the answer is Mr oth yes you did I
found out last night from Twitter staff
that you suppressed my account for this
tweet it's a freaking joke about Hillary
Clinton being angry that she couldn't
rig her election it's a joke but in
response being the Sinister overlords
that you all are you placed a 90-day
account filter so I could not be found
and now we see here that Twitter staff
said the visibility filter on my account
excluded me from top searches prevented
notifications for non-followers and much
more this is considered an aggressive
visibility filter you silenced members
of Congress from communicating with
their constituents you could you
silenced me from communicating with the
American people over a freaking joke now
who the hell do you think that you are
election interference yeah I would say
that that was taking place because of
you for sitting here the hunter Biden
laptop story was suppressed a sitting
member of Congress was suppressed a
sitting president was banned from
Twitter you know I bet that Putin is
sitting in the Kremlin wishing he had as
much election in her intervention
interference as you for here today we've
heard about threats to democracy well
what about shutting down a duly elected
member of Congress this is fundamental
to our nation's governance and you all
attacked that very Foundation if
they did this in coordination with the
government then we have an epic Scandal
and it seems like we do have that
[Music]